I am like 99% sure that there are some
sort of infectious disease in this
kitchen hey everybody my name is Ashley
and today I have a little bit of an
unusual video for you
it is a clean with me video maybe you've
heard of them maybe you haven't I just
discovered them recently and I am
totally hooked they are basically vlogs
of people cleaning their houses and I
know what you're thinking hmm that
sounds more boring than actually
cleaning but I promise for some reason
it is not they are totally mesmerizing I
am completely hooked I can't stop
watching and now all I want to do is
clean my apartment so I'm gonna take you
guys along for the ride I hope you enjoy
I hope it inspired you to maybe clean
one of your own spaces and yeah I got a
lot of work to do so let's go get
scrubbing
[Music]
this is why I am emptying the entire
kitchen first things like this soap scum
and stuff would have never even noticed
if I hadn't removed the soap container
the dish rack and all those things you
just don't realize the scum and stuff
that is building up in your life
[Applause]
[Music]
the kitchen is empty it's looking pretty
good and now it is time for admittedly
my least favorite part of this whole
thing and that is scrubbing and
sanitizing
[Music]
okay let's see if that worked I don't
know
whoa okay this hack is a good one
[Music]
[Music]
it is not to start my all-time favorite
part of any deep cleaning organizing
[Music]
[Music]